what's going on everyone it is axl beats
here for anime uproar and as you know
anime has tons of assassins spread
throughout it but today i'm focusing on
the zoldic family specifically i still
remember when i learned about kayla's
family and how different and interesting
they were so i'm super excited to get
into it if you've been enjoying our
hunter hunter content and you want to
see more show some support by leaving a
like and commenting on this video it is
the best way to let us know that you
want to see more and it really does help
with the youtube algorithm and of course
remember to subscribe so you always see
our content as soon as it comes out
finally you can also follow anime upper
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
or you can follow myself at excellionyt
and of course this video might contain
some hunter hunter spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the zoldics are considered to be
the greatest family of assassin in the
world of hunter hunter with each of them
having unique and deadly skills most of
whom are immune to all poisons as well
as resistant to pain and electricity
while also being strong enough to open
the 16-ton door guarding their estate
before they even learn men even as
children they are prolific for example
killua reaching the 200th floor of
heaven's arena at the age of 8 or kaluto
joining the phantom troupe at the age of
10. each zoldic begins training
immediately from birth in general
assassin techniques and martial arts
however as they grow older they can
begin to focus on specific talents or
fields so with the basics of these
zoltics out of the way let's get into
the individual members as i think it
makes the most sense let's start out
with kilauea kilowatt acts as a
secondary protagonist for much of the
series and he is the third oldest child
in his family while he is the current
heir to the zoldic assassination
business and the family as a whole
kilauea doesn't really want to fulfill
that role this is to the point that he
even runs away from home to become a
hunter something which changes just
about everything for him as he meets gon
during his hunter exams and gains a
whole new perspective on life
killua always had this really cool
duality to him he can go from this
mischievous kid who's a little bit too
honest and sometimes offensive to
someone who is deadly serious and brutal
just in terms of psychology killa is
incredibly interesting he's his
character who was tortured and abused
growing up but remains fairly optimistic
in nearly every situation there's only
really one time that this optimism fades
he was brainwashed so that whenever he
came across a stronger enemy for example
his brother illumi he would be forced to
run however once kilowatt removes the
pin which was implanted in his brain he
starts to overcome that fear very
quickly in general kilua is a balance
for gon when gon is blindingly
optimistic and hopeful kilua acts as a
way to bring some reality to the series
and when gon has a descent into madness
killua then acts as a voice of reason
and hope so let's talk about kilauea's
abilities as mentioned previous he is
immune to poison he can deal with
electricity and pain pretty easily but
his assassin training also leads him to
be extremely fast and strong as well in
less tangible forms this also helped
lead him to having tremendous ability to
size up other people understanding how
strong they are in relation to himself
and others with just a glance something
which gone doesn't really have the
ability to do at first before we get
into his nen as an assassin kilauea also
has access to other abilities as well
and of course this goes for most of the
members of the zoldic family silent
gates which makes their steps silent and
rhythm echo which creates after images
of himself to disorient his opponents
now on to his nen killua is a transmuter
type with his bread and butter ability
seeing him turning his nen aura into
electricity essentially turning him into
a human stun gun at its peak kilauea can
use this electricity to make him move
automatically and react to his
surroundings or counter-attack this
ability is called whirlwind he could
also use his electricity to boost his
own running and jumping speed with
godspeed using the same principle now
these abilities are great but they are
limited by the amount of energy that
they use and how low the amount of
energy kilua has is and finally
kilauea's most powerful weapon is all
the drip he has my god this guy changes
clothes like every 10 episodes and it's
always great next up is the eldest
zoldic child with illumi he's probably
the creepiest member of the family in my
opinion with a strange contrast in how
he looks and how he talks despite having
a nearly emotionless expression he
always talks in this kind of joyful and
innocent way however that all changes
when it comes to work where he becomes
absolutely ruthless we've seen a kind of
obsession and overprotectiveness towards
killua from illumi similar to the one
that their mother has but this is often
shown in a very twisted way for example
trying to keep him safe by implanting a
pin in his brain that forces him to run
away from strong opponents while in
general the zoldics have a rule against
killing each other illumi sees no qualms
about using the other members as he
actively wants to gain control of alaka
and her powers
all of illumi's abilities outside of the
typical assassin set revolve around
needles which is just great by sticking
them into his own face he can manipulate
how he looks often disguising himself as
a man named gitaraker he can also
implant needles into other people for
several different effects including
hypnotizing them controlling their
corpses or even just giving them an
order that must be completed illumi is
honestly a pretty cool and unique
character through all of anime not just
in hunter hunter even despite seeming so
flat on the surface his interesting
abilities and contrasting personality
traits just make him super memorable yes
super creepy but still super memorable
miluki might be the least interesting in
the zoldix and that's probably because
of his less than unique design and the
fact that he isn't really a fighting
kind of character miluki is a bit
overweight he's an otaku and like the
stereotypical kind of otaku you know not
the fun kind he's selfish quick to anger
and he's very much a coward so you know
lots of redeeming qualities we really
get our first taste of him during the
zoldic family arc as with most of the
members however when we get to meet
miluki he is torturing and whipping his
brother kilua who has chained to the
wall
not a great introduction i'm going to be
honest as i mentioned though many of the
zoldicks have their own specialty and
while miluki isn't a fighter he is kind
of more of a behind the scenes guy
hacking inventing all that he can often
feel a little bit flat as a character
sort of relying on those stereotypes of
the otaku and the hacker man vibes
that's probably why he falls so short to
me honestly if any of you like this dude
let me know in the comments and tell me
why cause i just don't see it on the
other hand we have aluka who is both a
jelly bean of adorableness and kind of a
horrifying monster who just wants to be
loved all at once
this might actually be one of my
favorite characters in the series she is
super interesting to me alaka was
possessed by a dark continent creature
named nanika and together they share her
body we were always told about how
soulless and uncontrollable she was but
then we actually meet her and she's like
the sweetest girl ever killua apparently
brings out the best in her though as he
always treats her well and it seems like
he's the only one to do so making a
really interesting dynamic around her
character she is especially cool though
because of nanika the creature
inhabiting her nanika has this
incredible nen ability which allows them
to grant wishes with seemingly no limits
on them the only condition is that
whoever the next person that aluko
requests things of has to complete three
tasks and if they can't that new person
and the one that they love most will be
crushed to death the bigger the previous
wish the more and more people beyond
those two will die as a result because
of this alaka is more or less locked
away to keep people from being killed
however kilauea does make the argument
that their family kills many more people
than alaka ever could the biggest thing
we see her do throughout the series is
obviously healing gone after his
transformation and after that she and
kilauea begin traveling together kaluto
is the final child of the zoldicks and
most notably he's seen replacing hisoka
in the phantom troop kawato is probably
the least well defined in terms of his
own personality among his siblings he's
quiet obedient and just kind of always
does whatever he's told
despite this kaluto in general has an
innate sense of superiority sometimes
leading him to brutally toying with his
opponents and extending a fight however
he's not too proud to realize that he
actually might be the one lagging behind
for example he quickly realizes that he
is weaker than many of the other people
in the phantom troop while not exactly
being the most powerful man ability
kalutos is actually really cool he's a
manipulator who specializes in
paper-based abilities this can be both
for surveillance and used offensively
with his surveillance paper dolls
ability he can attach a piece of
confetti to someone and with a paper
doll version of that person he can
listen in on everything happening around
them and if he needs to attack he can
use dance of the serpent's bite which
basically turns shreds of paper into a
tornado which revolves around the enemy
and slices them to bits it's not exactly
incredibly powerful but over time it
will definitely do some damage the
current leader of the zoldix and the
father of everyone mentioned so far is
silva zoldick while he looks a little
bit scary at first he's pretty calm and
restrained as a person he also seems
like he is just generally a good guy for
the most part you know aside from the
whole assassination thing as a father he
seems to believe that his children need
to make steps on their own for their own
personal journeys while he wants
kilowatt to become the next head of the
family and he is sure he eventually will
fill that role he still seems to respect
that killua isn't interested in that
right now and is willing to let him
travel the world with gon this is
actually pretty in line with silva's
philosophy for assassination believing
that no assassin should make their move
until victory is guaranteed
speaking of his assassination abilities
he is arguably the best in the world if
not then he's very close kilowatt
mentions how he can even take out a
man's heart without spilling a drop of
blood and that's when he's trying to be
sneaky if he actually wants to kill and
doesn't mind being a bit flashy he can
rely on his nen
just like kilauea he's a transmuter
creating massive balls of energy from
his aura that could be thrown at his
opponents and explode on impact
apparently being strong enough to even
kill people like zeno or crollo zeno is
silva's father and is probably one of
the best characters in the series he's
just this quick-witted old man who's
insanely powerful despite his age
it's likely that silva got his
philosophy on assassination from zeno as
the old man is much more of a strategist
than a head-on fighter as is the case
for the best of the zoldics zeno has a
pretty interesting moral code only
choosing to kill those that he has a
contract for killing and otherwise
trying to avoid killing innocent people
if possible for example we see him
losing his will to fight after
accidentally injuring the innocent
komugi choosing to leave the battle with
meruem after ensuring that no other
innocents would be hurt zeno just like
silva and killua is a transmuter but
where silvas seem to have also had a
knack for enhancer skills zenno has
instead developed his emitter skills
most of his abilities see him shaping
his aura into attacks such as aura
blasts or creating dragons to ride or
attack with at the end of the day zeno
is just kind of this stereotypical
powerful old anime dude with flashy
attacks but he also has a strong moral
compass and his dynamic within the
zolick family specifically how he adores
kalua and dislikes miluki just add a lot
of fun in there as well this dude kinda
feels like a grandpa that kids would
look up to and i've just always loved it
kikio is silva's wife and
she is a little bit crazy firstly it's
kind of hard to get past her design the
big poofy bustle gown her huge hat
bandages all over her body and that
cyborg like visor covering her eyes can
be a lot but when you add in her
obsessive doting over killua and the
heavy expectations that she has for him
as well as how she can become suspicious
of any friends that he makes because
they might ruin his potential you have
the makings of a crazy woman and that's
not even mentioning how violent and
cruel she is like yeah silva will kill
people but kikio will use and abuse them
and see nothing wrong with it there
isn't really that much that we know
about her outside of these obsessions
other than she was actually from meteor
city much like chrollo and much of the
phantom troupe and of course we still
don't know her net abilities now the
last two members we really don't have
much information on at all mahazik is
the oldest member being over 120 years
old all that we really know about him is
that he's an enhancer that netero is the
only person to fight him and survive and
that he has no connections personally
with anyone else in his family and
finally zeno is his grandson outside of
that he's just kind of this bald old guy
doing his own thing and lastly we have
zigg who had joined nero on his journey
to the dark continent in the past and
that's literally all we know about him
beyond this we have a slew of butlers
and servants who work for them people
like canary goto subone etc there's a
whole lot of them but in general they
all kind of serve the same purpose to
serve and protect the family as best as
they can however the most important
zoldic servant definitely has to be mike
who is just a good boy and that wraps up
this video on the zoldic family there
are a ton of cool characters in here and
also miluki and kikio but who are your
favorites for me it's definitely between
aluka and zeno i love aluka's character
so much and the idea of faustian wishes
is always one of my favorite tropes but
the twist of them affecting the next
person rather than the wisher itself is
so so cool and zeno is just kind of zeno
you know what more do you need let me
know your own opinions down below though
and if you enjoy this video and you want
to see more hunter hunter content on
this channel be sure to leave a like and
comment down below letting us know which
other videos you might want to see it
only takes a second but it really does
help with the youtube algorithm and of
course if you haven't subscribed to
anime uproar make this the video that
you do so by making sure to click that
bell and selecting all notifications you
can also follow anime upper on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt i want to
give a big thank you to all of our
patrons over on patreon who allow videos
like this to be possible especially the
patron of legend the one who's
acknowledged by lord twego himself alpha
sigma as well are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all clans in
grata patahepha al-jatal hinokami and
water the toasted chi the spike 8227
corey mcgowan dylan isadore spidey life
tenell tungsten tarkus baked buddhist
cody hebert and monkey d quilly finally
our pro hero tier patrons gilgamesh the
red haired raven annel cruz rathwind de
ora very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted no ted fatboy games
and soulrise slice and dice if you enjoy
our work or maybe think we just offer a
little bit of extra enjoyment in your
day-to-day life please consider going to
patreon.com anime uproar and supporting
the channel for as little as one dollar
you will get your name featured in
future videos as well as have access to
our exclusive patron only discord you
can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe option but whichever way
you support us you will get these same
great benefits thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time stay
excellent
[Music]
okay